قال الدفاع المدني السوري ان الفرقه تمكنت
من انقاذ طفله وعائله من تحت الانقاض في
مدينه عفرين شمال شرقي سوريا
تمام تمام
ايه معلش وقف
شو لازمكم هلا اموركم تمام
عمر اخر التحديثات والمعلومات
نعم اود الحديث بدايه عن هذا المبنى الذي
يظهر خلفي ما زالت عمليات انتشال الضحايا
من تحت المبنى مستمره تم انتشال خمسه عشر
شخصا نجوا من تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى هناك
شخصين فقط
فارقوا الحياه تحت هذا المبنى ما يزال
هناك سبعه اشخاص تحت هذا المبنى وما تزال
هناك تسمع اصوات وهذا الامر يجعل من فرق
الانقاذ
تسرع لاخراج العالقين تحت هذه تحت هذه
تحت هذا المبنى الذي سقط اتحدث لنا بان ما
حدث معهم هو شبه معجزه هناك خرج معظم من
كانوا تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى المدمر كما
تشاهدونه معظم من كانوا تحت هذا المبنى
خرجوا من تحت الانقاض وهم على قيد الحياه
باستثناء رجل فرق الحياه تحت هذا المبنى
لهذا لهذا المبنى كنت قد وصلت اليه بعد
حدوث الزلزال بعده دقائق وكنت اسمع اصوات
اشخاص تحت هذا المبنى وكنت امني النفس بان
يتم انقاذهم وهذا ما حصل وهذا الشيء الذي
افرحنا وان شاء الله يعني نسمع اخبار اخرى
لانقاذ من تبقوا تحت هذا تحت هذا تحت ركاب
هذا المبنى مع حديث عن انه يتم سماع اصوات
الاشخاص الذين تحت الركام هناك سبعه اشخاص
لعائلتين تحت ركاب هذا المنزل هذا المبنى
الواقع وسط مدينه غازيه عنتاب في منطقه
غازي مختار باشا هنا عوائل الاشخاص الذين
تم انتشالهم من تحت الانقاض وهنا ايضا
عوائل لاشخاص ما زالوا تحت تحت الانقاض
نستطيع ان نتحدث اليهم قليلا
الحمد لله رب العالمين بعد ما انهدم مع
مصالح زلزال مباشره ربع ساعه ونص ساعه
تقريبا شكرا